do you remember us
[Music]
we are still here
we never left
do you remember
welcome to the man man this is a game
where you're a serial killer with no
bones
well i guess they call prom a knight to
remember what are they called lexie and
why do they call prom night to remember
why i didn't go to prom for our final
story the serial killer the man man is
still at large
authorities warn that although he has no
bones
he's still extremely deadly
okay
they urge residents to keep doors locked
and windows closed at all times i see an
open window
that does it for the evening news
back to your regular programming
of now that's what i call weird music to
sleep to volume 25.
oh that is weird music to sleep to
oh
why do i have a butt
why is there a butt below the s why do i
have a butt button
oh
what
no
no
no
oh no
oh you better watch out man you
shouldn't have left your window open oh
my god what in the world
oh no
oh this is fantastic don't wake up
don't wake up the man man is here but
much but is it like a
worm situation where i got a wiggle worm
okay there's gotta be uh get the knife i
don't see a knife here it must be in the
kitchen
yeah you'll rue the day that you
you left your window open for the man
man to get you
so i have to like
whoa
how am i up
oh god a knife
perfect
ah just what the madman ordered
you better watch out you better not oh
it's backwards because i'm on my back
ah i see
well that's weird that's why the butt's
there in the s so that i can
properly executed
oh
whoa i could walk i might be able to
walk i
daryl
you're done for daryl
daryl you'll rue the day
i i'm not sure how i was able to walk
but i was for a brief moment
oh
daryl
oh daryl
oh daryl
hang on wait back up a bit
scoot becky
let's scoot this way
yes you're done for daryl
really thrown it back for daryl one last
show
oh my god kill crawling carl how am i
gonna do that wait wait wait back that
ass up you're done for carl you're done
for carl get back here you think you can
take this kill from me oh i'm on the
wrong buttons that's why it's not
working
here we go
oh crawling carl you wish you would not
be able to rue the day
yeah okay hold on i gotta turn around
hold on let me back back up here no
crawling carl you get back here how do i
why am i now not able to do what i need
to do oh you're done for oh
you're done for
oh you're done no
hey carl
now
carl you bastard
i'll kill you ha ha
get him
[Music]
like seeing do text speech for that
crawling carl got away which means you
lost no you don't get a cool losing
screen why would i reward you for losing
i'd say try again but can you imagine if
you lost twice in a row that would
probably feel so bad i'm not even gonna
give you a reset button reset buttons
are for winners
well
this is why i don't like coop okay let's
try that again the hunt is on
i gotta get good at
movement that's what i got to get good
at
well this is not what you would call
good at movement
so you have to kind of like go a little
bit right a little bit left a little bit
right a little bit left
and then you actually end up going up
right which is weird and i'm backwards
ah well
that's not what you like to see see what
i don't know is how to turn around
so then i get caught up like this
and i back my ass up on the door frame
there we go now we've got it
actually kind of got to be careful like
slow and controlled a cold calculated
killing machine who just so happens to
be under a table
all right you're done for daryl
daryl daryl
the man man is here
don't you worry daryl
the man man is coming for you
the man
my hand is getting tired god i bet
there's people that do crazy speed runs
of this
i bet you guys are going to do crazy
speed runs of this
all right now oh wait i'm actually
facing the correct way
not really whoa hold on okay back up
and i'm all twisted this is literally
the least convenient place to be in
oh are you yes
if i could just get on my belly
you'd be done for
this is how did i get twisted like this
this is
literally the worst outcome this is the
worst multiverse
are you kidding me
why i can't stab like no
yes yes yes yes stab stab come on all
right you thought you could get away no
not today aha and stab
wow
hey cool yeah i did it now i'm uh done
i'm not gonna do that anymore i killed
him final time 2 minutes 43 8 57 you who
i'm like whoa
oh god
hi
hi man man
how you doing good to see you um
well this is concerning i'm just gonna
i'm gonna go
very good very very good but
unfortunately all done for now but you
guys can play more if you want to link
in the description
moving on
this is alone in hell i see you you
bastard i'm gonna play
hell looks an awful lot like a house
where am i i don't know
last thing i remember is hearing sirens
they were also
shouting police officers commanding me
to get down on my knees what did i do
what did i do
hello
oh i can open it
a flashlight weird yeah that is kind of
weird finally someone acknowledged it
just automatically having a flashlight
everywhere is weird
i've had power outages and i haven't had
flashlights in reach what's up with this
bathroom it's creepy as hell why
looks pretty ordinary to me i never pee
or poop anymore it's like my urinary
system has completely disappeared this
place is driving me nuts i can feel it
in my bones
i too feel many things in my bones
i feel that in my bones
what the hell is that sound
i don't know
oh
go
back to
i used to be able to read but now i
can't even do that feels like the world
is crumbling down on me
alright is it though
but is it though go back i'm gonna go
back oh hello i don't know why but i'm
never hungry anymore i haven't drunk
water for what it feels like a year i've
already forgotten the taste of every
food i've ever eaten have you now
well that's not good
i'm going back
uh oh can i help
are you happy with yourself
i mean for oh [ __ ] i mean for the most
part yeah can i pick your hey hey
hey hey hey now hey i'm alone in hell i
didn't read that one
okay
sure
what did i do why am i doing this the
world has surely abandoned me now all i
see are these masked people do they even
exist what you you see you see mass
people where where do you uh see mass
people what why did you do it
i did it
you are dead
am i okay cool
why who hey
am i in hell oh no what have i done i
don't know why
hello
oh my god
oh
jump scare incoming everybody
you don't
deserve
how you deserve
much much worse it's kind of hard to
read that
i didn't know if i
hello
someone there
someone jumped you're gonna go to jump
out of me
oh
well
why i don't know how could you do this i
don't know shut up i didn't do anything
could you i don't know how could you
i just listened to what my bones tell me
oh oh hi okay
welcome to hell
oh this thing so bad
hi buddy
hey buddy
hey pal hey how you doing
so
welp
okay you know
please touch the credits to quit okay
you know
for your first horror game
i will say this is pretty good you had
some dynamic things happening right the
notes were a little like obtuse the text
on the wall is very hard to read zelda
only works for certain i think like one
word things however
that being said it made me creeped out a
few times there
ah
but i feel like you needed a bigger
finish on it it is during our darkest
moments that we must focus to see the
light if you look at what you have in
life you'll always have more if you look
at what you don't have in life you'll
never have enough
oprah winfrey
wise words not bad
not bad at all for the first
horror game a great starting point
better than what most people would do
which is not even start to make a horror
game but also it's better than some of
the first horror games i've played uh in
the past so pretty good
but moving on
this is grain wind incident 77 an urban
explorer enters the grain wind
production factory the premise has long
been abandoned and shut down many years
ago due to unknown circumstances a
recovered tape named incident 77 is
found near the premise showing the
events that took place before the tape
was
discovered
play tape oh
it's like some uh found footage analog
horror type thing
i thought it was something different
oh no it is
it is a game
[Music]
love the style love that guy nice belly
button
how did i get in here
why did i get in
here i don't like this
oh i don't like that
i don't like it when i have to open the
doors manually
nice a drill press
nice
reports on grain wind production
facility in recent news the factory has
been rumored to have poor working
conditions and security regulations
further investigation into the ongoing
case proceeds as the facility is being
sued for five million dollars
hi
that's me it's me said why is there
anything
hey
why is there an eye at the top of the
screen no no i like the letter i an
eyeball
oh i do not like this
oh i don't i don't like this
[Music]
god i can slip did i just slip down the
stairs because i wasn't looking okay
that was interesting
okay it's a light good
but
i'll kill you i'm really soul
hey
okay you just just go swirling up in the
stairwell you know how it'd be they do
that i won't bother you
stop i will not help you
what am i looking at
oh
you can cut that [ __ ]
i'm just gonna have a friendly
companion during my travels okay i don't
know what that's about but i don't see
anything that i can use
[Applause]
he's trying to do asmr for me i really
appreciate it but i'm not really an asmr
kind of guy
[Music]
okay
all visitors must report to security
okay
okay fascinating
creepy
hurrah
well i guess i could fall in there and
die
but let's not do that
oh i can zoom
you
oh hello
work-related death incident reports at
greenwind production factory a worker
has lost his life this weekend when an
oil canister exploded nearby as he was
working on the elevator shaft the
explosion proved to be fatal as the man
fell to his death while lit on fire and
was dead before he even hit the bottom
of the elevator our condolences go out
to his family further investigation into
the facility's safety measure awaits
great
good to know
what am i looking okay
[Music]
none of that
none of that
none of that now you're here
i can't read the rest of that
oh god oh interesting
okay well before i go in there
let me see what's up here
oh that's fun
i don't know if i want to do that
okay
all right
good
oh
oh that looks terrible
what
huh
huh why would you do that oh hi oh hey
okay so i could technically climb up the
elevator
how far up does this go
[Music]
i'm just gonna go to the top because
i slipped again oh no oh no no no
oh no
oh no
oh no i shout
hello
hi how are you
hello
hey
lady
[Applause]
lust okay um
not why
i'm not feeling particularly lustful at
this moment but i'm at the top so i
might as well keep going up
okay
ye why am i on the roof why would i be
oh hi
hello
what's she doing up there
hello okay um
[Music]
well this is uh
oh
ah
ongoing lawsuits proceed towards grain
wind facility as the ceo and owner of
the facility is going bankrupt in other
news of production and processing of
produce has been halted by 70 percent
the facility has not met protocol or
ongoing standards further involvement
into the matter awaits
okay um well that's ooh
uh
let me just
hey bud
oh my god what is that
okay some wicked whistling through the
wimbly woods
this is uh
i don't know if i can climb down you
know there's something in the way
there's just so happens to be something
in the way
all right i'll try please excuse me
pardon me i'm going down
hello
oh
really
oh that's i already knew about that wait
but how do i get down here
okay
well apparently i can climb up and
okay
all right so that was uh
nothing so there's other ways to go
around here and let me try this one
first because it seems cool and i like
parkour
and i'm an expert at parkour no one
questioned that or me or anything i ever
say
why would i never tell the truth
why wouldn't i always go without
ah damn it well that's my own fault
because i jumped off the ledge what else
could i have possibly expected from that
action all right up i go i guess
hello ah you weren't here so what was
the point of coming over here
was there any
was it to witness something horrible
horribly witnessed
all right i'll go this way then
hope nothing horrible's waiting for me
i'm charging in blindly i'm not too sure
about this
why have i not gotten any of the the
close-up jump scares and things and
stuff
i can't get through there
okay
maybe there's a way around
seems like there used to be a ladder
there but no
those barrels are in the way
yeah i just can't get under there it
just quiet can't quite get under there
maybe there's like a tool i could find i
don't know i haven't even encountered
anything
tool-esque
up here's lust lady
hey lust lady
[Applause]
all right
oh
climb down here this is different
oh
okay
ah
this is good
and this drops down here perfect
perfect moscow news this week further
tragic news about grain wind production
facility due to being overworked and
working upwards of 100 hours a week
workers have become ill and this week
even even worse fate occurred a young
man jumped from the railing of the silo
area of the facility the man was killed
in an instant and his family are
heartbroken they are blaming the
facility for causing him to do this the
facility ceo is now he has spoken but
interviewers are trying to get to him
that's weird because that's what i did
accidentally
i am not look i'm not thinking too deep
about that one
oh
okay okay i get it
okay let's see if i can get under here
though oh great
good good stuff
great
stop
where am i going there's a big ladder
where am i
i'm meant the silo
[Music]
oh
no yes no maybe so
can i not
get out i don't think that's as intended
so why oh here we go
grain wind production facility produces
10 tons of processed grain every month
the use and purpose of the 12 grain
silos a grain win is a part of the
farming process which is to store excess
grain product that can be used and sold
commercially in the future as the
company is off schedule in its
production food regulators and factory
inspectors have been called to the
facility well that's some good lore but
uh
i still don't know necessarily what i'm
trying to accomplish am i just trying to
find all the newspapers is that my
objective
whoa
okay
today's story about the apartment blocks
residing nearby the grain wind
production facility residents have been
complaining about an increase in noise
from the factory even though it's been
abandoned for many years the residents
complain about the generator and other
equipment randomly turning on and making
lots of loud noises during the night no
one truly knows why these disturbances
continue one resident committed suicide
and hung themselves from their apartment
window he said the voices from the
factory drove him to insanity truly
disturbing news on this day we have to
bring some more light onto these ongoing
events very soon i'm sure you do i'm
sure you do
maybe it is just to find all the
newspapers
oh no man
i guess i could go around
but why would i want to why
there's no way up
nah
holy
cow
oh hi
hello
what are you doing
i'm climbing down
oh
boy
oh god
okay
where am i going
why am i going
oh
no
hey bud how you doing is this to my
death that would have been to my death
why would i have done that to my death
did you try to lure me to my death bro
bro
not very bro like
bro why would you do that bro well i'm
not gonna do that
oh no
but that was something else
okay but so far so far whoa that's new
wait a minute
that was not there before definitely 100
not there before
okay
so how and why and also how do i get
back
yeah i know i feel it i feel you i feel
you bud i i feel you
dude i feel you
oh that ain't good
how do i get back because i jumped off
the roof to get here but it doesn't seem
like i can get back up the roof
oh that wasn't there before either wait
a minute okay so both of them have
something in them interesting
why
hello why
tell me why
oh that wasn't that was open i i believe
it was but why is this
well
oh my
god why
would you do that
oh
i can crouch even lower
i was doing this which is control
what
but apparently you can press c to go
even lower i didn't know that there's
two
crouches is that always open
i don't remember this being open
interesting
what was uh-huh
another tragic event
25 year old woman was found the bottom
of the large grain style as one broker
neck and an answer from the fall workers
say the event occurred due to old rusty
ladders found within some of the silos
like the one that i just climbed upon
like the one that i just descended
oh hello oh i thought that was it yeah
you can see what i was seeing right
okay good
i guess i'll go back now
i'll go
[Music]
i don't know what that is supposed to be
oh
ah
what
what what where where why what why why
where am i
oh
uh hello
your statues are people i'm gonna assume
people put maybe statues i don't know um
so uh
so yeah um
you want me to stand right here you
gonna flame me alive you gonna peel my
fingernails off
hmm you gonna let me leave
those zoinks
oh this ain't good
you're just gonna let me film everything
hmm oh well that didn't sound good oh no
hi oh no no
don't
ending one of three sacrifice a tape was
recovered from an abandoned church
nearby in the same town that the grain
wind production facility is located an
urban explorer's dead body was found by
local police in an abandoned church the
body had been severely mutilated and the
words
dis said date were carved into the chest
of the victim further investigation into
the events leading up to the tragedies
are being looked into by the federal
authorities the abandoned church and the
old grain wind facility were connected
in a series of ritualistic sacrifices
and missing people reports throughout
the years apparently these people
worship some woman who died at the age
of 25 in one of the grain silos as an
entity to had taken over the girl's body
and the people nearby are said to have
sacrificed people to appease this said
entity further interviews and
investigation is to be done as the
content of the recovered tape is still
being analyzed the event has been named
incident 77 no further questions will be
available to be answered regarding this
case
well there you have it one of three damn
i'm not gonna play through all those
endings but if you would like to play
through that and find the other endings
it's available through the link in the
description very good i jumped quite a
few times very fun
do you
for
remember
we're coming for you
[Music]